>>> JOHN BERMAN HERE, IN FOR
ANDERSON.
ONE OF THE JOYS OF THIS JOB USED
TO BE WONDERING WHAT THE NEW
DAY -- NO PLUG INTENDED -- WOULD
BRING.
NOT ANYMORE.
NOW, IT'S WATCHING HEADLINES
LIKE THESE POP UP.
QUOTE, HERE'S WHY YOU SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT U.S. DEMOCRACY
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S FROM CNN.COM POLITICAL
ANALYST ZACH WOLF AND, YEAH,
IT'S A THING.
>> THE DING DONGS WHO SACKED THE
CAPITOL LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS LIKE WHEN AL QAEDA
TRIED TO TAKE DOWN THE WORLD
TRADE CENTER THE FIRST TIME WITH
A VAN.
IT WAS A JOKE.
BUT THE NEXT TIME, THEY CAME
BACK WITH PLANES.
>> BILL MUIR MISSPOKE THERE.
AS FOR THE REST, THE NOTION THAT
FORMER PRESIDENT INCITED IN
JANUARY WAS ONLY A DRESS
REHEARSAL?
WELL, LISTEN TO SOMEONE WHO DOES
SERIOUS FOR A LIVING.
YESTERDAY ON CBS NEWS,
FORMER-NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SENIOR OFFICIAL FIONA HILL WAS
ASKED ABOUT JOINT CHIEFS
CHAIRMAN MARK MILLEY'S QUOTE IN
BOB WOODWARD AND ROBERT COSTA'S
NEW BOOK "PERIL" COMPARING
JANUARY 6th TO, QUOTE, THE GREAT
DRESS REHEARSAL.
HER ANSWER IS CHILLING.
>> WELL, YOU'RE A RUSSIA
ANALYST.
YOU KNOW IMMEDIATELY WHAT THAT
PHRASE IS WHICH IS WHAT LENNON
CALLED AN UPRISING THAT PRECEDED
THE REVOLUTION.
I READ THAT AND I SAID, DEAR
GOD.
>> YEAH.
>> I MEAN, HE -- THE -- THE
GENERAL IS SAYING THAT THIS IS A
PRECURSOR, POTENTIALLY, TO
FURTHER VIOLENCE?
IS -- IS THIS OVERSTATING THINGS
IN A HISTORICAL SENSE?
>> HE'S NOT OVERSTATING IT AT
ALL BECAUSE I MEAN WE ALL SAW,
IN REAL-TIME, WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th.
AT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
I MEAN, THIS IS EXACTLY THE
THING THAT YOU THINK OF IN
REVOLUTIONS, STORMING THE
BASTILLE DURING THE FRENCH
REVOLUTION.
STORMING THE WINTER PALACE
DURING THE RUSSIAN REVOLUTION
THAT GENERAL MILLEY WAS ALLUDING
TO.
AND AS HE WAS SAYING, WE HAVE
SEEN MANY HISTORICAL EPISODES
WHERE THERE IS VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE DISCOUNT IT.
THEY THINK THAT THIS IS JUST A
PASSING OCCURRENCE.
>> JUST A PASSING OCCURRENCE.
YOU MEAN, LIKE MIKE PENCE, THE
ONE RIOTERS WANTED TO LYNCH
CALLING IT QUOTE ONE DAY IN
JANUARY?
THAT KIND OF THING?
WELL, IF THAT WERE ALL IT WAS,
IT WOULD BE BAD ENOUGH AND
DESTRUCTIVE ENOUGH TO THE TRUTH
WHICH ANY HEALTHY DEMOCRACY
ARRESTS ON BUT IT'S NOT JUST
REWRITING THE HISTORY OF ONE
DAY.
IT'S REWRITING THE HISTORY OF
ANOTHER.
ELECTION DAY, 20 20.
HERE'S A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP DOING IT
OVER THE WEEKEND WHEN ASKED IF
HE THOUGHT THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
>> WELL, CHRIS, I'VE BEEN VERY
CLEAR FROM THE BEGINNING.
IF YOU LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
STATES, THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW THEIR
STATE-PASSED LAWS THAT GOVERN
THE ELECTION FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT IS WHAT THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
THEY DON'T SAY THAT THE STATES
DETERMINE WHAT THE RULES ARE.
THEY SAY THE STATE LEGISLATURES
DETERMINE THE RULES.
>> BUT THE STATES ALL
CERTIFIED -- THE STATES ALL
CERTIFIED.
RIGHT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, ARE
WE GOING TO FOLLOW WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS OR NOT?
I HOPE WE GET BACK TO WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
BUT CLEARLY, IN A NUMBER OF
STATES, THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW THOSE
LEGISLATIVELY SET RULES.
>> SO YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
STOLE -- STOLEN?
>> WHAT I SAID IS THERE ARE
STATES THAT DIDN'T FOLLOW THEIR
LEGISLATIVELY SET RULES.
THAT'S WHAT THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
>> DO YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN?
>> AND IT'S NOT JUST
IRREGULAR -- IT'S STATES THAT
DID NOT FOLLOW THE LAWS SET
WHICH THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW.
WHEN YOU SEE STATES LIKE GEORGIA
CLEANING UP SOME OF THE MESS,
AND PEOPLE CALLING THAT JIM CROW
LAW, THAT'S A FLAT-OUT LIE.
>> HE SIMPLY COULD NOT SAY WHAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS IN 50 STATES
CERTIFIED IN 60-SOME-ODD COURT
CASES REAFFIRMED.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE REWRITING
THE HISTORY OF THAT DAY, EITHER.
HERE'S SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY
WHO CERTAINLY KNOWS BETTER
TRYING TO REWRITE JANUARY 3rd.
THAT'S THE DAY, ACCORDING TO
TESTIMONY FROM SOMEONE IN THE
ROOM, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DISCUSSED DECAPITATING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
APPOINTING AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
SOMEONE WHO WOULD SUPPORT HIS
DEMANDS AS HE TRIED TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION.
>> THAT WAS THE ADVICE THAT ONE
PERSON IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WAS SUGGESTED BUT JUST ONE
PERSON.
AND HE -- HE REJECTED ALL THAT.
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT A
SCENARIO THAT HE WAS TRYING TO
GET THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YES, THAT'S THE SAME SENATOR
GRASSLEY WHO IS RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION AND WHO STOOD ON
STAGE SATURDAY WITH THE MAN HE
ONCE SAID -- AND I AM QUOTING
FROM HIS STATEMENT HERE --
QUOTE, DISPLAYED POOR LEADERSHIP
IN HIS WORDS AND ACTIONS.
UNQUOTE.
HE SAID ON THE 13th OF FEBRUARY,
AND BEFORE THAT ON JANUARY
7th -- THE DAY AFTER THE
INSURRECTION -- SO ANOTHER TWO
DAYS REWRITTEN.
BUT, IT TAKES MORE TO CREATE THE
DANGER OF A POLITICAL UPRISING
THAN JUST THE WHOLESALE CREATION
OF AN ALTERNATE MYTH TO EXPLAIN
A DEFEAT AS CONFEDERATE STATES
DID WITH THE LOST CAUSE OR NAZIS
CLAIMED THAT THE BETRAYAL FROM
WITHIN WAS THE REASON GERMANY
LOST THE FIRST WORLD WAR.
IT ALSO TAKES SOME TO RALLY
BEHIND WHICH IS WHY THIS PROGRAM
TRIES TO PLAY THE RAMBLINGS OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SPARINGLY,
IF AT ALL.
BUT IN THIS CASE, BECAUSE HE IS
THE MAN WHOM REPUBLICANS LIKE
CHUCK GRASSLEY, MIKE PENCE,
STEVE SCALISE, AND ALL BUT A FEW
LAWMAKERS HAVE CHOSEN TO SUPLY
DATE THEMSELVES TO, HERE IS A
SAMPLING OF WHAT HE SAID IN IOWA
THIS WEEKEND.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, THE
SINGLE-BIGGEST ISSUE, AS BAD AS
THE BORDER IS, IT'S HORRIBLE.
HORRIBLE.
AS BAD AS THAT IS, THE
SINGLE-BIGGEST ISSUE, THE ISSUE
THAT GETS THE MOST -- THE MOST
PULL.
THE MOST RESPECT.
THE BIGGEST CHEERS IS TALKING
ABOUT THE ELECTION FRAUD OF 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS SCARED OR
IMPOTENT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
THE SUPREME COURT REFUSED TO
HEAR THE CASE BY TEXAS AND
ALMOST 20 OTHER STATES.
THEY RULE AGAINST ME ALL THE
TIME.
ALL THE TIME.
VERY PERSONAL RULINGS.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS BUT
NEVER LIKE THIS.
THIS, AGAIN, THEY USED COVID IN
ORDER TO CHEAT WITH ALL OF THESE
BALLOTS AND ALL OF THIS EARLY
VOTING AND LATE VOTING.
WE ARE ONE MOVEMENT, ONE PEOPLE,
ONE FAMILY, AND ONE GLORIOUS
NATION UNDER GOD.
AND TOGETHER, WE WILL MAKE
AMERICA POWERFUL, AGAIN.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT THIS
WEEKEND.
ALSO, HERE TRYING, YET AGAIN, TO
TURN A MEMBER OF A VIOLENT
INSURRECTIONIST MOB INTO A HERO.
>> MY GREAT HONOR TO GATHER
TODAY TO CHERISH THE MEMORIES OF
ASHLI BABBITT.
A TRULY INCREDIBLE PERSON.
THERE WAS NO REASON ASHLI SHOULD
HAVE LOST HER LIFE THAT DAY.
>> JUST TO REMIND YOU, ASHLI
BABBITT WAS A WOMAN WHO FELL
UNDER THE SWAY OF THE QANON
CONSPIRACY, THEN INCITED BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S RALLY THAT
DAY WAS PART OF A VIOLENT MOB
THAT BROKE INTO THE CAPITOL.
THE MOB BEAT AND WOUNDED 140
POLICE OFFICERS AND WANTED TO
LYNCH THE VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE WAS SHOT AND KILLED TRYING
TO BREAK INTO A SECURE HALLWAY
WITH FLEEING CONGRESS MEMBERS
JUST STEPS AWAY.
AND NOW, THOSE VERY SAME
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS, WITH ONLY
A FEW RARE EXCEPTIONS, ARE
HITCHING THEIR WAGONS TO THE MAN
AND THE IDEA RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
WORST ACT OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
AND IN RED STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S PROMPTING, STATE
LEGISLATURES ARE IMPOSING NEW
LAWS MAKING ELECTIONS TOUGHER TO
VOTE IN BUT EASIER FOR PARTISAN
FORCES TO CHALLENGE.
ALSO, AT THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
URGINGS, REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
BEGUN REPLACING ELECTION
OFFICIALS WITH TRUMP LOYALISTS.
EACH DAY SEEMS TO BRING ANOTHER
HEADLINE.
NONE SEEMS TO BRING ANY JOY.
JOINING US NOW, TWO CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATORS.
BOTH OF THEM, CONSERVATIVES.
MIKE SHIELDS, WHO ADVISES HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
AND S.E. CUPP.
S.E., THEY ARE LEADERS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SCALISE IS PERPETUATING THE BIG
LIE.
AND GRASSLEY IS KIND OF COMING
UP WITH THIS NEW LIE THAT TRUMP
WAS SOMEHOW THE VICTIM IN THE
INSURRECTION.
WHAT DOES THIS DO TO THE PARTY?
AND WHAT DOES THIS DO TO THE
COUNTRY?
>> WELL, IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT
TO THE COUNTRY TO WATCH TWO
GROWN MEN SO EMASCULATED.
SO AFRAID OF LOSING DONALD
TRUMP'S SUPPORT AND SUPPORTERS.
UM, AND UNABLE TO SAY WHAT IS --
WHAT WE ALL KNOW TO BE TRUE.
UM, IT' DEEPLY DISAPPOINTING.
BUT I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S WORSE.
IN SOME WAYS, PEOPLE LIKE STEVE
SCALISE, LAWMAKERS LIKE CHUCK
GRASSLEY -- UM -- LEANING INTO
THIS AND REALLY GIVING IT THEIR
FULL WEIGHT IS, I THINK, WORSE
THAN TRUMP DOING IT.
THE IDEA THAT TRUMP LIES AND
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO TELL THE
TRUTH OR DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
FACTS.
THAT'S ALMOST BAKED INTO THE
CAKE EVEN AMONGST HIS
SUPPORTERS.
BUT THE IDEA THAT LAWMAKERS ARE
GOING ALONG WITH IT, VERY
SERIOUSLY.
NOT FLIPPANTLY BUT SERIOUSLY
GOING ALONG WITH IT, I THINK,
GIVES IT A LOT OF CREDIT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE TUNING INTO FOX
NEWS.
MAYBE, WHO ARE DISAFFECTED
VOTERS AND THINK, WELL, IF THEY
ARE SAYING IT, SURELY, IT MUST
BE TRUE BECAUSE NO ONE SEEMS TO
BE FACT CHECKING THIS, YOU KNOW,
ON SOME OF THE RIGHT-WING MEDIA
AIRWAVES.
SO I THINK IT'S -- IT'S ACTUALLY
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS, WHAT STEVE
SCALISE AND CHUCK GRASSLEY AND
MANY OTHER REP